The street signs for the new US embassy have already gone up.
This usually quiet, residential neighborhood in south Jerusalem
has become the focus of the world's attention.
"The building behind me, which currently houses
the consular services of the US,
will become the new American Embassy.
Moving the embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem is highly controversial.
The international consensus remains that the status of the city
should be agreed upon through negotiations."
For now, only the US ambassador and a limited number of staff offices will move to Jerusalem from Tel Aviv.
The complete relocation will take many years.
A majority of Israelis supports the US move
– like here in downtown West Jerusalem.
"Jerusalem is, after all, the capital of Israel; I believe it, and of course there will be,
I believe there should be someday a Palestinian state.
and if they want part of Jerusalem, someday they’ll
find an agreement.
But I think it’s OK the US does move the
embassy over here, because this is after all the capital.
In Israel, ask every kid what’s our capital: It's Jerusalem."
"I think the American Embassy should be in
Jerusalem.
I think all the embassies, including the US
embassy of course, should be in Jerusalem,
because Jerusalem is the capital of Israel."
Observers say that the de facto recognition
by the US will have long-term consequences:
"Jerusalem today is more divided,
more binational, less sustainable
and more contested than ever before.
And nothing has changed about that.
This move is a hollow gesture.
On the other hand, it indicates a collapse
of the United States stewardship over political processes
and tells the Palestinians and the
Arab world,
'Abandon hope, you are about to lose Jerusalem.'"
On the other side of town, in East Jerusalem,
Palestinians are following the move closely.
They want this part of the city to be their
capital in a future independent state.
Many here say that the US President is giving
away something that is not his to give.
"If they move the US embassy, whatever
they do, Palestine will remain Arab.
We will defend this land,
we are present, and it's our greatest right to live in this land."
"Moving the embassy to Jerusalem shows only one thing:
It shows completely that the Americans are on the side of the Israelis.
They do not care about Palestinian rights."
"For many
Palestinians, the US has long lost its role as an honest broker in any peace initiative.
And while the Palestinians' dream of statehood fades,
Israel is hoping that more countries will follow
the US's lead and move their embassies to Jerusalem."